here we are answering questions that
people have sent in amy has the
mainstream media covered this election
fairly absolutely not let's have a
season without polls okay instead of the
media pouring millions of dollars into
these polls that turn out to be wrong I
mean there's a poll every week or every
two weeks what is it it's a it's a
primary or a caucus and then yes find
out who voted who didn't vote and of
course the vast majority of people don't
vote but pour that energy and those
millions of dollars pour those
investigations into what these
candidates really represent what their
records are instead of they spend all
their times doing the false polls that
they themselves admit how did we get it
so wrong and then they spend that time
from polls polls saying how did we get
it so wrong but instead we need to know
what these people represent I think we
know I'm sick of what they represent I'm
telling you I could do their act for
them I agree with Amy and we just look
at the way they've covered Donald Trump
they've given him kind of unlimited
coverage they allowed him to call him
even on the Sunday morning shows and you
know you had Bob Woodward supposedly
this journalistic icon interview him for
90 minutes and not ask him once about
his being a birther about his wanting to
ban an entire religion about his
inciting violence nothing well and if we
had no polls what with Donald Trump talk
about hey I mean look at Lund doesn't do
what he pulls himself look at one day
March 15th I think they called it Super
Tuesday 3/5 primaries you had Ohio
Kasich one is first you had Florida
Marco Rubio pulled out you had North
Carolina Illinois and Missouri okay so
you won Florida knocker lost and pulled
out Kasich won oh right okay so every
candidate all the networks covered the
election that night the primaries that
night and you heard from Cruz you heard
from Kasich you heard from Rubio you
heard from Hillary and then they waited
and waited and waited for Trump they
said he's gonna hold the news conference
they showed the empty podium fine and
then they play his whole thing we all
will wait where will we go inhale ice
Trump where
he's a uniter where was Bernie Sanders
do you know where was Bernie Sanders
that night oh did he go to sleep I mean
Arianna might have been happy then but
what did he do he was speaking to
thousands of people in fact they never
played even two minutes of his speech
they never even mentioned where is
Bernie tonight
they suck we all agree okay uh Susan on
the 25th anniversary of Tomlin Louise
what are your thoughts looking back on
the iconic film stands up holds up that
movie boy I saw it recently but they're
really 25 years Wow that's my loss same
year is uh need a help oh yeah oh that's
interesting
all right well I mean I think that the
interesting thing about families well
that was interesting
ah that was significant um it wasn't his
first movie but it was the first movie
where we got to see so much I never saw
him before then oh yeah he was did some
TV and stuff good anyway every woman in
this audience know exactly what scene
you were talking yeah and some of the
men I think that was what was
interesting was that it we had no idea
people were going to be so offended it
was in the you know it was like Butch
Cassidy and the Sundance Kid except with
women then it got in cars or trucks and
it just made me one oh did the reviews
people because we were condoning suicide
it just made people so upset and I think
what it was was that women had the
option of violence and that we I don't
know what it was exactly but that's how
we got it on the cover of Time magazine
and that's because there was such you
forget that there was a backlash against
it but it was huge and we didn't see
that coming dude forget yeah yeah
iconic no no no they got really what
that upset and we were like whoa I
didn't know we backed into this
territory held by white heterosexual men
of a certain age
yeah it was a big yeah just weren't a
minority I thought uh ariana de sleeping
pills work actually sleeping pills are a
major disaster fifty eight billion
dollars are spent around the world on
sleeping aids and they're like a master
like ambien yeah and what is amazing is
that people think if they can't sleep
this is their only alternative instead
of all the natural alternative hot
that's natural or cognitively we had one
- Oh hot keeps me up you're not smoking
the right kind what it here on sativa
you should go to the other side you
think I don't know I mean while so why
are you smoking that up goodbye Vicki
future don't Paganini how to play the
violin okay New Zealand and our country
is the only two countries are allowing
sleeping pill advertised right ah so you
have any kind of prescription yeah you
have all these beautiful pictures of
happy people and sleeping pills and then
ninety-two warning signals of what can
happen to you well I mean here's here's
my thing about drugs
all drugs wear off over time except for
pot and liquor pot liquor always work
they may they may have a some
diminishing returns not to have to tell
you Rick
[ __ ] pot
Rick looks like Satan everything I don't
mean that in a bad way
cuz Satan was a good was a very
good-looking man that's but I didn't
think when I see Satan night iti got oh
that's Satan
um and again not as a bad thing but you
know there aren't many drugs that I will
actually make it possible for you to
wake up in the middle of the night have
absolutely no memory get in a car well
drive and kill people that's ambien okay
yeah I'm not pretty sick I just know it
is absolutely but you don't it's going
to hate that here was what I was gonna
say about drugs most of them the more
you do them the less they work and the
worst example of that is sleeping pills
yes it'll work the first time and then
six months later you'll need to take
twice as much and then your Elvis I mean
the amount the amount of sleeping pills
that Elvis Presley was taking at the
time of his death would kill an elephant
if an elephant took it the very first
time it was Michael Jackson really
propath all right you even like hook me
up I'm taking a nap that was heavy
crazy it is always a stat is truly a
slippery slope once you start with
sleeping pill because you will always
need more wow they have this connection
between sleeping pills and Alzheimer's
sleeping oh really
practically every disease if you take
them over six months which a lot of us
do not me alright um having just marked
another equal pay day this week are we
getting any closer to closing the wage
gap between men and women
no you never will it's always gonna be a
political issue cuz they wanted to be a
political issue who wants it well you
can also ask the White House to pay
their people the same it says you can to
pay their what the same
so their next topic it's not a real
issue it's it's some of it in other
words how is real issue and it wasn't
real issue I remember my mother you know
she went when I was growing up she
taught herself she didn't have any
skills she taught herself the 10 key to
type and she single mother and she
worked her way she's finished got her
MBA a remarkable story well um but it is
the law I mean with the equal play is
the law so we can law I suppose and we
have another law on long and ten years
now a little time your snow why do we
link open for the same job well here
here's the the 77 cents which is what
everyone use 7 or 78 cents on the dollar
even Obama's economic advisors when
pushed have had to say on equal pay day
a couple years ago yeah that stat is
actually not the one that really works
and when the White House is pushed on
well according to this stat you guys are
not paying women the same amount and
they go well we're close I mean it's a
not a good measure for whether this is a
problem and there are plenty of other
things there are plenty of things about
the pay structure that are a problem and
then but women prioritize different
things and it's just more complicated
than the 77 cents argument I'm for it
women should get equal pay right but
don't make it but it's been a political
issue is that why Ted Cruz fired you
never for when I was making it too much
yeah well anyone to bring the balance ya
know he needed a sacrificial lamb right
that's what
do I look kind of lamps here no you look
like say le Xavier day one you have a
lot of range I'm eating that as
accomplice is happening I'm telling you
look at this man is this not what Satan
look like it is I'm just I'm not saying
at the time
yeah we're distracting okay do you like
oh it's fine but not for saying I really
saying you needed like a black thing
like this look this time yeah maybe that
kind of sweet yeah Arianna what can you
tell us about your partnership with uber
to combat drowsy driving well what is so
interesting is that after the designated
driver campaign in the 80s drunk driving
deaths and crashes have been huffed
but drowsy driving dents are going up
and last year we had eight thousand
deaths and 1.2 million crashes and so
partnered with uber to highlight the
problem we have a pledge on change.org
that people can take that they're not
going to let their friends drive while
drowsy they want themselves drive
without rui-zi
and I've been doing ride alongs with
uber drivers really yes people can
actually request me on the uber app to
give them in San Francisco Travis the
founder of uber and I did it together
and we got this woman and from Houston
and we explained to her about the
dangers of drowsy driving and we gave
her a bag of a lot of goodies because
you know but the point is that a lot of
people who take uber sometimes also
drive and the whole idea is to raise
awareness about the fat there are now
right sharing technologies there are
different events over so she wasn't
driving how do I explain that's it
please again Arianna in your uber I
believe that Lane that she looks the
same as she did when she made telling
louise and she doesn't sleep did she
make a deal with Satan
really I mean she does not look like she
would you sound like that the back of
science
I'm just asking no no no you're the
nineteen-fifties you know when you would
say tobacco is bad for you and there
would be this tobacco scientist camera
but there is this 95 5 year old woman
who's been smoking all her life right no
no today's the exception to there right
she looks magnificent her skin is
perfect and she doesn't sleep but I
don't arrest you for the rest of
humanity it doesn't work you have to I'm
on your page because believe me you know
me I care a lot about health night Rito
everything I can and if you don't sleep
right it throws off everything else
bye there what not to be gross but if
you don't sleep right you don't poop
right right and if you don't poop right
everything turns and what about my right
yeah I'm not saying you don't poop i oh
I would never say that all right
cold and a toddler is there hope for me
absolutely first of all they will grow
up I promise so ten years from now yeah
but also you need a little tribe you
need a support system we need to all
rally around you and what are you think
about the fact that everybody on the
panel felt the need to have their phones
right on I mean I remember when I doing
this show and people you know they know
I just wouldn't bring a phone why didn't
you need them on television
you're just Satan is never without his
phone all right thank you everybody
you